نقل مراسل الجزيره في افغانستان مصر امنيه
ان مسلحين انتحاريين هجما مسجدا تابعا
لحزب الحزب الاسلامي بزعامه قلب الدين
حكمتيار جنوبيه العاصمه كابول وقال مصر
امني ان الهجوم خلف قتلى وجرحى اثرى
شباكات وقعت عند المدخل الرئيسي للمسجد
وعقب الهجوم قال قلب الدين حكمتيار في
تصريحين عقب الحادث ان انتحاريين اثنين
فشله في اغتياله واطلق النار على المصلين
الذين كانوا خارج المسجد
المؤمن
بالنار كونتي
من محاوله اغتيال من يقفون وراء الهجوم
حاولوا سابقا لكنهم لم ينجحوا دخل مهاجمان
في زي النسائي للتموين وكان يرتديان
حزامين ناسفين واطلقان نيران على الذين
كانوا خارج المسجد قتل من افراد حمايه شخص
واحد واصيب اخران سنعرف لاحقا من يقف وراء
هذه المحاوله